I got the latest on the Roseanne thing
some people now think there's a
possibility the show Roseanne could come
back after all yeah this is true many
fans have started an online petition
urging ABC to continue the show Roseanne
without Roseanne bring it back bring
Roseanne back without Roseanne is what
they're saying and in a related story
Andy has turned at a similar petition
about the show Conan so I got I got 12
signature yeah we'll talk about that
later yeah all right I think you'd
missed me I really do the latest rumor
in Washington is that President Trump
could decide to pardon himself this
would be completely constitutional
according to Trump's new Supreme Court
justice Donald Trump himself
that's I practice think you'd be a good
judge actually housecleaning there
what's that oh boy
he'd enjoy it I think he'd enjoy himself
speaking speaking of the Supreme Court
the Supreme Court ruled that a baker in
Colorado can refuse can refused to make
a wedding cake for a same-sex couple on
religious grounds
yeah now less gentleman in my opinion if
there's anything America is not gonna
stand for it's less cake I don't care
what your views are we like that freedom
of cake is in the Constitution yeah I
think it is yes yes let's see what's
gonna hey in an interview today just
today former President Bill Clinton said
he does not Oh Monica Lewinsky an
apology yeah Clinton said what I do owe
her is a new dress that's the one thing
people had to think a little bit that
was one of those oldies but goodies the
good old 90s Kim jong-un said he wants
to open a McDonald's in North Korea yeah
which may explain why the summit with
president Trump suddenly back on Kanye
West in the in the news in a new
interview Kanye West talks about being
bipolar says he's bipolar yeah funny I
said sometimes he loves himself but
other times he really loves himself
constant prepping Kanye in the United
Kingdom a baby's first word was Alexa
the baby's next words were getting me
new parents they showed up on Amazon the
next day and then is my last joke I mean
in my career this is this is it ladies
and gentlemen but true story a man in
Michigan is under arrest for having sex
with a basset hound with a basset hound
yeah and you thought the basset hound
looks sad before
I started that miming thing where you
walked to tend to walk down the stair
yeah halfway I was like a screw it yeah
hard on the knees that's a sign that I'd
been in the business a long time the
Conan in his 20s would have gone all the
way down this Kona's leg huh huh
you